vu qu'on a clairement des difficultés à
devenir les maîtres du monde
j'ai fait appel à un consultant pour
voir où ça cafouille alors un petit peu
cher mais il paraît que ça vole haut
alors mon travail ici c'est de faire un
bilan de compétences de groupes messas
alimentaire parce qu'en vrai même
passion c'est la botanique
les courses de chariots et la natation
synchronisée
pour évaluer le potentiel d'un groupe en
général je prends le premier jour pour
les points faibles
le deuxième jour les points forts et le
troisième jour on fait une synthèse avec
eux j'en suis à 4 jours de points
faibles
j'ai dû annuler des truc perso et tout
quelles sont vos principales qualités
les épées c'est pas une qualité si avec
la vitesse
quels sont vos principaux défauts quand
je couvre direct jeune âge comment
rendre hommage à un noble
non il n'y a rien de sexuel dans la
question c'est comment saluer un noble
salutations pourquoi l'accent combien de
langues parlées vous je comprends pas
une question quelle serait votre
première décision si vous étiez roi le
droit d'avoir me veut je parle de
décision il n'y a pas de génie dans
l'histoire oui j'ai beau lire est le
royalisme donc vous annulez quoi je suis
bon en énigme alors j'ai étudié vos
faiblesses que j'ai ajouté dans ce
tableau
j'ai aussi bien sûr étudié vos forces
mais il semblerait que vous n'en ayez
pas ce que va prendre quelque chose
qu'on ne s'est pas déjà l'acheter
incompétence social problèmes de lecture
c'était écrit petit il faut savoir
qu'une armée a entre 7000 et dix mille
soldats vous 183 villageois c'est des
fermiers soldats web en attendant il y
en a deux qui m'ont rendu leurs armes
heures en pensant qu'ils étaient
pompiers
la seule dame du palais et pas instruite
pour la cour et votre chef
il n'a pas vraiment l'autorité ça
j'aimerais père est enfin finie exact
donc pour conquérir le trône de fer
j'ai trois solutions en tête soit vous
pouvez prouver que vous avez un vrai
fils de dragon descendent nancy roy soit
vous trouvez une stratégie dans laquelle
les points forts c'est d'avoir
énormément de points faibles
soit vous avez une sorcière qui crée un
univers parallèle dans lequel vous
seriez l'exact opposé des gros ringard
que vous êtes à l'heure actuelle je
préfère
les remises en question c'est toujours
positif sauf celle-là cela je la trouve
des plantes hockey n'était pas prêt tout
de suite tout de suite et à quelques
pistes va réfléchir la stratégie prend
une sorcière aussi serait pas mal
benmoussa seraient eux je les dis mais
c'est pas possible
[Musique]
on